you guys were together well you know for
how long for 20 something years before
you stopped yeah 10 maybe yeah around 10
years and then what was it was there an
event was there something that sparked
hey let's do this again in our 50s or
whatever because you know it's it's it's
it's like what was it some sort of
excitement something like okay we have
more to do here no but eventually yes I
mean was but yes maybe I don't know I
can't speak for I don't know I mean I
know that we love playing and we and all
the within those years we did get
together in in you know my home and and
play in the b in the studi you know
right keo's had a rig there that never
left I mean it just it was just always
there so and
um so we did get together we got
together I look back in you know videos
and stuff there's like 2011 I see that
we were there and you know you know
iPhone has dates I'm like oh we
were there in 2011 and then certain
times 2015 so we did sort of bomb in and
get together but I guess we made a
conscious decision to try to do
something um sort of right around after
the pandemic there we uped at up at the
Matrix Premiere in San Francisco and we
as Brett was saying we had a
conversation about gear or something and
we kind of nerded out about that and and
we just I don't know the timing just
sort of came together and we just
we got together and played and it just
sounded good let's give it a try yeah
yeah I I guess so it's like I guess you
don't know what you're getting into
until you just get into it yeah and
Brett was living in San Francisco at the
time so he came down and stayed with me
and um I think it was great to sort of
it was sort of like you know that
Beatles movie where all they all sleep
in the same was it a hard days tonight
or help help were they're all like
sleeping in that living room and those
beds like sunken beds it kind of felt
like that you know we get up and have
breakfast together and then want to come
over spend 8 hours and we we kind of did
Camp it was like Camp right and then I
don't know how it happened but we came
up with 12 songs I honestly and how long
10 minutes no how long was that we had
more than 12 songs right 15 I think but
how long was that a couple two weeks or
three weeks um probably if you're
looking about talking about days spent
probably what 21 days
overall Jesus three different sessions
of look how prolific eight days gone for
a month come back another 8 Days kind of
thing and what do you send voice memos
to each other you have an idea for a
song you want you guys send it no it was
all done in the same room candy grams we
sent each candy there was nothing really
other than you know if Koo had a Bas
riff or something he would bring that in
but there was really no no writing done
singularly I don't think on this one was
just kind
of I have this idea or you know Rob
would just start playing a beat and then
we just look at each other and go we
recorded everything so we got lucky we
caught every every little moment every
the entire session yeah everything we
did we record whenever we liked
something we like when we on to
something we record just like that's a
lot of hours to go through no no uh
who's the one out of the three of you
that usually doesn't like stuff as much
as the others who's more
critical probably Rob Rob yeah and what
will does he kind of foot around
it does he kind of go like no he sits in
his throne and he looks down with his
good judgment and says that is not what
you should be doing I don't like that
hey guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a sold out
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited